so let me start by asking the question
that I think a lot of us find ourselves
wondering about which is the current
generation really different from the
earlier generation is it over simplified
to say that people of my age were really
engaged in in protest in in trying to
object to the way the world was and try
to change it in that sort of way whereas
the current generation is much more
concerned about helping individual
people working within school systems
working within not-for-profits but is
there a difference and if there is a
difference what brought that about and
what is it is there anything in that
change that that is important for us to
know it's also possible it's an
oversimplification or wrong Diane what
do you think so I think what we have now
is a real pointed ways that service is
highlighted services encouraged and a
real pathway for those that choose to
serve I think my position that I am the
first I'm New York City's first ever
chief service officer but really I am
the nation's first chief service officer
and we are incredibly excited we meaning
the mayor's office Mayor Bloomberg to
have the support of foundations such as
Rockefeller where we have reached
recently launched the ability to have a
city's of service and so we plan before
June for there to be ten other cheap
surface officers across this country and
so I don't know if the difference is
fundamentally the people of the
generation or if it is rather that what
we are seeing now is an outgrowth of the
former generations commitment to service
and we're seeing the fruits of that but
you said something that I
you want my old one you said something I
think is worth highlighting as possible
and that is that the structures that are
now available to help into service right
really critical to having more of it
more now and definitely and they're
clearer yeah I completely agree with
that I think what we've seen is an
evolution of the opportunities for
service not only being clarified but
being expanded not only service to
cities or to our nation but increasingly
service around the world and those
mechanisms certainly in my day as an
undergraduate we're simply not available
ruin and I think that is one crucial
issue but I'll go back to Lee's original
question and as a well-trained Columbia
social psychologists say that I really
do think it's a person's situation
interaction so I think we all are
products of our times and I do think
that in the crucible of the 60s people
really were burned with a sense that
they could change the world we felt we
stopped the war we and our actions after
that were really very much influenced by
that set of experiences those who
followed in the 70s and 80s had a
different set of experiences and I think
it made them different in response to
their view of how directly they felt
they could impact political processes
and political outcomes so that I think
what we started to see at the end of the
last century was people seeking more
individualized ways to express their
service aspirations because they could
see a more tangible causes that's
interesting yeah i tutor and I can
produce this road cop right I asked my
government to do something
so I you know and nothing happens anyway
and I think one of the resonances why
young people were so attracted to Barack
Obama and why they voted in such record
numbers was this return of the view that
maybe you could influence government
that government could be there in a way
that you could feel would be directly
affected by what you believed in and how
what outcomes you wanted to produce and
it'll be really interesting to see now
this generation who has both the formal
structures and now perhaps the belief in
a more tangible cause and effect I've
come into politics and what they will
produce I think it will be fascinating
yes very interesting do it's a very
interesting question I think you are
asking and I'm wondering exactly what
the new generation young people today
are doing that you didn't do for example
but i think you know each generation has
its own challenges if i think back in
this country in the united states in the
Western world what was going on during
slavery people were fighting how do we
abolish slavery for example that were no
was one of the challenges that that
generation hit and if we go back to
African countries for example what was
going on for so many years colonialism
who actually was thinking about or that
there was that generation I was born
during independence they didn't seek
organisms so my parents will say so what
what do you do what is your next
challenge for example so I don't think
about colonialism I don't think about
eNOS slavery or something else I think
about something else and I think this is
exactly what you know what makes
difference between you know generations
but today maybe people here for example
in
in any medical field for example the
example of HIV I think the new
generation has been facing a huge
challenge how do we actually tackle this
issue of HIV for example eight years ago
or or so there were stories actually not
you know just until recently about
whether HIV drug for example could be
given to poor people in African
countries and there were a lot of
questions one of my friend poor farmer
who worked so hard in Haiti and giving
HIV drugs to poor people who and we were
talking about poor people those who have
no roof we have have no shelter have
nothing to eat you know poor people can
take HIV drugs in it and how did he
actually work with people with the
students I give an example of faith days
for example which was started by
students at Stanford and they raised the
awareness there is a lot of money and
you can see that you know a lot of
people in colleges in lab even high
school are becoming aware of these
horrible disease and really changing the
world now HIV drugs available to
everyone who always able to see
healthcare provider so i think it's in
every generation has its challenges and
it is important to also know how how do
we communicate for example did you have
access to internet for example how did
we reach out you know people now there's
a lot available i'm sure i think you
know think about all is well i mean i
think where you and Rudy just said is
worth pausing on because